we'll always remember these beloved
actors for their roles on our favorite
tv comedies but they had to move on with
their lives and start families
find new sources of income or just leave
the public eye
here are the real reasons you don't hear
from these sitcoms stars anymore
michael c morona is best known as big
pete from the adventures of pete and
pete
one of the most acclaimed and surreal
kids shows ever made the narrator and
the closest thing the show had to a
voice of reason
big pete is fondly remembered by a
generation of nick fans
you know the feeling you get after you
hear your favorite song for the first
time
all you want to do is play it again and
again so it stays stuck in your head
forever
morona himself went on to star in
several ameritrade commercials as
stewart
ads that anyone around then will tell
you were inescapable
moroni has sparsely acted since 2004 and
with good reason
he's now behind the camera and is one of
the most prominent onset electricians in
hollywood
he attended purchase college and studied
filmmaking since then he's worked on
shows like elementary
jessica jones luke cage blue bloods and
the deuce
if you watched a marvel show on netflix
you've probably seen morona's work
morona also co-hosts a podcast called
the adventures of danny and mike with
pete and pete co-pete danny tambarelli
where they look back on their days and
quote
wander out into the world in search of
their next great adventure
anyone raised on a steady diet of 90s
nickelodeon remembers kel mitchell's all
that characters like good burger cashier
ed
or snake bit coach creeton even more
remember his turn as the dim-witted kell
kimball
on keenan and kell but while keenan
thompson soared to new heights and
remains a television fixture almost
three decades later
kel faded away the contrast was so stark
that a rumor about him being dead
circulated during the myspace days
what happened turns out he's doing fine
hey
hey yeah i'm here what's up well what a
swimsuit
keenan and kell as themselves both tried
out for saturday night live at the same
time
only keenan got the call kel then
focused on making smaller movies
still the guest spots on tv including
various newer knicks shows like sam and
cats
and started a family he's since reunited
with keenan a few times
including doing a good burger reunion on
the tonight show and
as executive producers on the all that
reboot but his main focus has been his
faith
kel is a deeply religious man he worked
with his church ministry for years
before becoming a licensed pastor for
spirit food christian center in december
2019
he's also had parts in several christian
movies including she is not my sister
he also had a part in a true rite of
passage a guest spot on dancing with the
stars
where he finished second kel never gets
upset hearing about his past projects
though
they were an integral part of his life
in his own words
even though will smith has done i am
legend and all these
other great films you still love him for
fresh prince of bel air
hillary banks is best summed up by the
phrase dad i need 300
the fashionable spoiled brat with no
common sense the role of hillary
made actress karen parsons one of the
most recognizable actresses of the 90s
the recognition carried parsons until
the new millennium at which point the
roles dried up and she disappeared from
her screens
but she never went away she just changed
direction with so few roles for
african-american women in the 90s
parsons found herself rejected or passed
over
often her career faltering and in need
of a change of scenery
parsons moved to new york she met
filmmaker alexander rockwell
and married him in 2003. they had a
daughter that same year and a son in
2007
these events changed her priorities no
longer having the time to pursue
auditions and memorize lines while
taking care of kids
she turned her focus to writing in 2005
she founded sweet blackberry
an organization dedicated to teaching
children about little-known parts of
african-american history
it's since produced many animated short
films with a-list voice talent
she also published a book how high the
moon in 2019
based on stories about her mother's
experiences in the jim crow era south
originally worried about what her
daughter would learn in school she's
used her talents to shape the
conversation and make sure
children know their history taryn noah
smith played mark taylor the youngest
son of tim and jill taylor on home
improvement
the sensitive boy turned proto-goth
turned sensitive boy again was a stark
contrast to his more rambunctious
brothers and the role made smith stand
out as an actor
but while smith's life after child
stardom isn't exactly dark and
depressing it
is unusual smith quit acting after home
improvement ended no longer interested
in performing after it consumed his
entire childhood
he then briefly became tabloid fodder
partly because he married a woman 16
years as senior while he was 17
and partly because he was suing his
parents after claiming they mishandled
his trust fund
years later he chalked this up to a
misunderstanding and reconciled with his
parents
these days smith has had an eclectic
assortment of jobs and hobbies he's an
installation artist around the country
at festivals and museums
which includes a floating art gallery he
built himself he did disaster relief
work in the philippines for a year and a
half in 2014.
in december 2017 he temporarily moved to
corpus christi texas
and helped with recovery from hurricane
harvey most recently
he's been teaching people how to pilot
submarines he's a member of the
community submersibles project
an organization based out of berkeley
california that gives members of the
public
hands-on training in submarines amanda
burst is best known for her turn as
marcy rhodes darcy on married with
children
the radical feminist neighbor of the
bundy clan the best friend of peg
and the nemesis of al marcy was a
mainstay of a popular show
you're so lucky even though yours is
about as desirable
as shredded wheat without the milk
at least he's cheap to keep burst
herself made headlines in 1993 when she
came out as gay in an era where that was
a rarity for high-profile celebrities
since married with children ended though
verse was seldom seen in front of a
camera
why because she stepped behind a camera
realizing that marcy would always be a
secondary character burst decided to
broaden her horizons by trying her hand
at directing
she turned out to have a talent for it
and directed upwards of 30 episodes of
married
when the show ended so did her acting
career so she could focus on directing
she went on to direct episodes of dharma
and greg reba and mad tv
she also directed the big gay sketch
show on logo which was the launch pad
for kate mckinnon's career
burst took a break from the industry to
raise her daughter after returning
directed the web series skirt chasers
and made her new york theater debut in
the off-broadway play party face in 2018
angus t jones first came to public
attention as jake harper the half of the
titular two and a half men
his later time on the show was marked by
offset controversy
most notably involvement in a
controversial religious movement
and calling the show he worked on quote
filth
man if you watch two and a half man
please stop watching two and a half man
i'm on to an app man i don't want to be
on it please stop watching it
he later apologized left the show and
came back for the finale
after all that he's mostly vanished
what's he been doing since then
trying his best to live a normal life
jones went to college at the university
of colorado at boulder and enjoyed his
time away from the spotlight
he distanced himself from organized
religion noting that he got
quote pretty doomsday with my thinking
and was happy moving away from that
he slowly made his way back to acting on
his own terms
including starring in louis c.k's
internet-based sitcom
horace and pete in 2016 jones joined
forces with justin combs
son of sean combs to create tonight an
entertainment and event company which
has a minimal web presence and seems to
have gone out of business
more than anything though he seems to
enjoy living life on his own terms
he spends time with his younger brother
otto doing his own projects at his own
pace
he's yet to rule out a return to the
screen but it's fully understandable
that after spending his entire childhood
on a set
he'd need some time to himself saved by
the belt the new class never had the
cachet or fan base of the original show
even though it ran longer lindsay mckeon
was one of the stars of the show as
swimmer and goody two-shoes katie
peterson
who transferred to bayside in season
four and stayed until the end
she later went on to star on guiding
line as mara lewis and appeared in eight
episodes of one tree help
mckeon still acts most notably in the
recurring role of tessa on supernatural
but also spends a lot of her time on
other ventures
specifically she spent the last few
years off and on as a lifestyle blogger
her now defunct website evolved by
lindsay presented itself as
somewhere to gather advice about health
and wellness diet
lifestyle and relationships she's also
good friends with chris evans with whom
she starred on the short-lived teen show
opposite sex
he gave a testimonial for her on her
website and was interviewed by her on
her youtube channel
john lejoice carved out a career as a
comedy musician before landing on the
league as taco macarthur
the perpetually stoned scheming and
songwriting taco was arguably the most
popular character on the show
from the birthday song to the maul
krampus to the ebdb
le joie as taco was responsible for some
of the most memorable moments on the
show
so why hasn't he been on our screens
since the league wrapped because he's
gone back to making music
lechois still released his own music
while on the league and after the show
ended in 2015 he made it his full-time
gig
he started performing serious folk rock
music in 2016 under the name wolfy's
just fine
named after a line from terminator 2.
wolfie's fine honey wolfie's just fine
what are you he released two albums
under this new moniker by 2018.
le choi isn't just making in his own
words quote
terribly unfunny music he also wrote
several of the songs on the soundtrack
for the lego movie 2.
this includes the acclaimed tune catchy
song which was the end result of
listening to a lot of katy perry k-pop
and songs produced by max martin
mimi bobek was arguably the most iconic
character on the drew carey show
drew's big bossy brash work nemesis was
one of the most recognizable characters
of the 90s and early 2000s
kathy kenny the actress who played her
received much attention for the role
enhanced by her occasional appearances
on whose line is it anyway in the
rotating chair
since the drew carey show ended though
kenny has become scarce
worry not though she's still using her
powers for good
she now plays the character of mrs p on
the website of the same name
the character in contrast to her most
famous role is friendly and helpful
she reads classic children's literature
to kids watching online
kenny is proud of the role and her part
in promoting literacy
noting i think that everything i am iota
reading
kenny has also written three books
including queen of your own life
the grown-up woman's guide to claiming
happiness and getting the life you
deserve
though she's mostly moved on from the
role of mimi she donned the makeup again
for a few appearances on the prices
right
mimi showed up as the new producer of
the show tormenting host drew carey
the real drew carey at that lori beth
denberg is best remembered for her time
dispensing vital information on all that
but she also had a recurring role on the
steve harvey show from 1998-2002
she played lydia the socially inept
overachiever and the foil to main
characters romeo and bullet had
outside of a brief appearance in
dodgeball though she hasn't done much
acting since
that's because in addition to touring
the nostalgia circuit she's picked up a
few new sources of income
i want to get into the other side of the
business these days denberg spends much
of her time officiating weddings
what started as a joke between her and a
friend turned into a lucrative business
denberg says on her site i do
personalized quirky weddings
val renewals and commitment ceremonies
for couples looking for something a
little different
a little less sterile and a little more
fun between 2012 and 2018 alone she
officiated 20 weddings
she's also on tour with the all that
edition of nostalgia personified
a show that looks back on 90s nick shows
from the perspective of denmark
danny tamarelli and michael c morona the
show began touring in the fall of 2019
and it's a good way to catch more than a
few people you might not have seen on tv
in a while
andrea elsin was on one season wonder
whiz kids before landing her most
iconic role as lynne tanner on elf
one of the titular alf's best friends
and the only daughter of the tanner clan
lynn was a popular character on a
popular series then elsin disappeared
from the entertainment business
where did she go melmak nope much closer
you can find her teaching in a
california yoga studio elsin was
introduced to yoga in 1993 by her future
sister-in-law and fell in love with it
she started taking training courses and
soon left hollywood behind to focus
entirely on family and yoga instruction
she spent years training and opened
grass valley yoga in grass valley
california
she told slow tv that she sold at circa
2014 when she moved to pismo beach
and opened what is now called yoga
village at arroyo grande
currently doing business under the name
annie hopper she's clearly put
lynn behind her beach yoga is probably a
better gig than acting anyway
delane matthews played beth the wife of
the titular character on
dave's world based on the writing of
miami herald humor columnist dave berry
dave's world was a minor rating success
floating around the top 20
early on and lasting for four seasons
the show went off the air in 1997
and is mostly forgotten today with most
of the cast staying out of show business
afterwards
nod matthews though who soldiered on in
hollywood for years to come
despite health issues will you stop
trying to top me you're not
sicker than i am matthews dealt with a
series of tv show cancellations
one right after the other before landing
dave's world
after dave's world went off the air she
had regular guest spots on various tv
shows
ranging from the shield to saving grace
she also had a recurring role on general
hospital from 2002 to 2003.
matthew's career ended in 2015. she was
diagnosed with scoliosis when she was 13
and dealt with it throughout her career
she had over eight surgeries to the
point where her
spine is encased in titanium she also
deals with hashimoto thyroid disease
and post-traumatic stress all things
considered though she seems to be doing
okay
in her own words i loved being an
actress and thought my career was my
identity
it wasn't it isn't i've been disabled
since july 1st 2015.
that isn't who i am either zachary
tybrian played brad taylor
the oldest and most rambunctious son on
home improvement
though brad frequently got in trouble
once famously caught smoking weed
brian himself lived a normal life and
did pretty well for himself
years after the series ended and he left
the public eye though he's still making
a name for himself as a filmmaker
and as an investor brian also continued
to act
including an appearance in the fast and
furious tokyo drift
before changing his focus in 2009 he
founded his own production company and
moved from in front of the camera to
behind it
he started by producing several horror
movies including rogue river and prowl
he recently retooled his focus and
released more popular and acclaimed
movies
like 2018's the kindergarten teacher
starring maggie gyllenhaal
which competed at sundance and was sold
to netflix brian is
also a cryptocurrency and blockchain
enthusiast he produced a movie about it
called bitxbit in bitcoin we trust
he's a core investor in discentric media
a digital news network dedicated
entirely to decentralized content
additionally he's the co-founder of
producer's market a company attempting
to streamline food distribution between
producers and buyers using blockchain
technology
ian lithgow had a recurring role on
third rock from the sun
as leon one of the oblivious students in
dick solomon's physics class
no i'm sorry leon you're raw no his last
name is not a coincidence
he's the son of dick solomon himself
john lithgow
ian appeared in 48 episodes of the
sitcom but was seldom seen on tv again
he's still acting but away from screens
and cameras and balances another
important job with it
ian graduated from harvard like his
father and acted for several years
including his turn on third rock during
this time he acted in play houses across
the country from manhattan to chicago to
pasadena in 2005 he got his master's
degree in clinical psychology from
antioch university los angeles
and then worked as a therapist in new
york city he moved to philadelphia in
2011
after his wife rachel a notable name and
jewish scholarship and nonprofit
management
got a job as the executive director of
the philadelphia holocaust remembrance
foundation
as he told content delaware he's used
this time to take a break from his time
as a therapist
and resume stage acting one such
production was a performance of the
outgoing tide with peter strauss
and michael lernen he has since
relocated back to new york and resumed
his therapy practice
so if you're in the big city and want to
see a big play and then talk about your
feelings after
there's at least a 50 50 chance you'll
see him one way or the other
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stars are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you